what do you think about people like
Aaron Schwartz I don't know if you're
familiar with him but uh he was somebody
uh who broke the law in the name of an
ethical ideal he uh downloaded and
released
um academic Publications that were
behind a paywall
and
um he was arrested for that and then
committed suicide and a lot of people
see him certainly in the MIT Community
but throughout the world as a hero
because
you look at the way knowledge scientific
knowledge is being put behind paywalls
it does seem somehow unethical
and he basically broke the law
to do the ethical thing
now you could challenge it maybe it is
unethical but that you know there's a
gray area and to me at least it is
ethical to me at least he is a hero
because I'm familiar with the paywall
created by
the institutions that hold these
Publications they're adding very little
value
so it is basically holding hostage the
work of millions of brilliant scientists
um
for for some kind of honestly a a crappy
capitalist institution like they're not
actually making that much money it
doesn't make any sense to me it should
to me it should all be open of Public
Access uh there's no reason it shouldn't
be all publication should be so he stood
for that ideal
and um
it was punished harshly for it that's
the other criticism that's too harshly
and of course
uh deeply unfortunately that also led to
a suicide because he was also tormented
on many levels I mean do you are you
familiar with him what do you think
about that line between what is legal
and what is ethical
so it's tough It's a tough case I mean
the the outcome was tragic obviously
um
unfortunately when you're in law
enforcement you have to your job is to
enforce the laws I mean you just not if
if you're told that you have to do a
certain case you know and there is a
violation of at the time you know 18 USC
10 10 30 uh computer hacking
um
you have to press forward with that I
mean that you have to charge the you
bring the case to the university office
and whether they're going to press
charges or not you know you can't
you can't really pick and choose what
you press and don't press for it I never
felt that at least that flexibility and
not in the FBI I mean maybe if you when
you're a street cop and you pull
somebody over you can let them go with a
warning so the FBI you're sitting in a
room but you're also you're also a human
being you have compassion you're
arrested Ross and the hand on the chest
I mean that's that's a human thing sure
so there's a but I'm I can't be the jury
for whether it was a good hack or a bad
hack
it's all someone a victim has come
forward and said we're the victim of
this and I agree with you because again
the basis of the internet was to share
academic thought yeah I mean that's
where the internet was born but it's not
it's not up to you so the the role of
the FBI
you didn't force the law correct